[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
an interesting what if scenario what if
harry potter hadn't been harry at all
what if harry had actually been a girl
okay let's start with the basics and get
the minor details out of the way that
kind of thing if harry potter had been a
girl of course his name wouldn't have
been harry at all would it so what would
it have been well as jk rowling revealed
on pottermore a few years back harry was
actually named after his great
grandfather henry potter or harry to his
intimates with this in mind if harry had
been a girl she likely would have been
named after one of her relatives as well
let's say then that james and lily
potter decided to name their baby girl
after james's grandmother euphemia
euphemia which means well-spoken or fair
speech and is pronounced like euphemia
was a popular name in early scotland
however it was eventually overtaken by
its nickname effie meaning our heroine's
formal name would have been euphemia but
she likely would have gone by the more
widely accepted and easier to pronounce
version of the name effie making our
female version of harry effie potter
so what would have been next for a
little effie doubtful much would have
changed in regard to her relationship
with her parents as limited as their
time was together lily surely would have
died trying to save her baby girl in the
same way she died protecting her baby
boy from voldemort's killing curse but
perhaps this leads us to another more
pertinent question would voldemort have
even come for the potters at all after
all the prophecy given by sybil truloany
in 1980 was about a boy who would be
born in july of that same year with the
ability to defeat lord voldemort of
course despite being born in july of
1980 this would have ruled out a
daughter by lily and james potter
leaving neville longbottom as the only
potential threat to the dark lord this
of course would have changed everything
effie potter unlike poor harry would
have grown up with a mum and dad she
would have been raised with the
knowledge that she was a witch who was
part of the wizarding world she likely
would have barely known the dursleys
lily's sister petunia petunia's husband
vernon nassan dudley this wouldn't have
been lily's choice of course but rather
a reflection of the dursley's disdain
for all things magic and in their
opinions unnatural so the three potters
may have continued to live in godric's
hollow and perhaps lily and james would
have eventually welcomed another child
or two into their family it stands to
reason that sirius black would have
still been effie's godfather based on
sirius's kind and caring disposition
towards harry one can only assume that
effie would have received the same love
and affection from her godfather of
course sirius never would have been
framed for the potter's murders and gone
to azkaban leaving him to nurture a
solid relationship with his goddaughter
in a way he was never able to with harry
it's pretty safe to say that effie
potter's formative years would have been
a lot less tragic than harry's she
wouldn't have been an orphan there was
no attempt on her life by a powerful
dark wizard and instead of being abused
and mistreated by her muggle relatives
she would have had a steadfast adoring
magical godfather there really is no
comparison is there so now that we've
gone through the early years of effie
potter that brings us to her time at
hogwarts how would effie's experience at
school have differed from harry's well
without any ties to lord voldemort harry
of course became the dark lord's
unintended seventh horcrux after he
attempted to murder harry intrinsically
linking the two effie would have been
sorted into gryffindor without question
this differs from harry who was almost
placed in southern by the sorting hat
but who ultimately went into gryffindor
due to his internal pleas with the hat
having been placed in gryffindor i'd
like to think that effie would have
befriended hermione and ron just as
harry did although i think maybe she met
the two once placed in the house rather
than at king's cross station and on the
hogwarts express
after all lily and james would have
taken effie to the train and known
exactly how to access platform nine and
three-quarters no need for help from the
friendly weasley clan she also may have
known one or two witches or wizards from
godric's hollow with whom she could have
sat with on the train in any case
similar to harry's friendships with ron
and hermione effie would have eventually
become best of friends with these two
it's not unreasonable then to consider
the possibility that this trio could
have ended up in a love triangle at some
point with both effie and hermione being
interested in ron however i suspect that
instead of ron being the love interest
for both girls perhaps effie developed a
crush on one of ron's older brothers if
i had to guess i'd say she fell for one
of the twins fred or george since fred
meets his demise in the final
installment of the series let's say it
was george keep things less tragic only
a couple years her senior both twins
were in gryffindor giving effy plenty of
time to become interested in either boy
as she likely wouldn't have spent as
much time at the weasley household due
to lily and james being alive effie may
also have played quidditch for
gryffindor just as harry did another way
in which she would have spent time with
the twins who were both beaters for the
house team so that about covers effie's
friendships and personal relationships
at school but what about her dynamics
with the professors a young effie who
may have looked a little more like her
mother than harry did could have
potentially had a very different
relationship with say professor snape
although she still would have been
james's child without these striking
physical resemblances to her father like
harry had and the fact that lily was
still alive severus likely wouldn't have
held the same contempt for effie in fact
if she looked much more like her mother
than her father he may have even favored
her add snape's interest in effie to the
fact that she would not have been the
chosen one from professor trelawny's
prophecy and i doubt that albus
dumbledore would have shown as much
interest in her as he did with harry so
it's possible to think that snape may
have even stepped in as her mentor
although stape still would have been the
head of slytherin house a long-standing
rival of gryffindor which in my opinion
makes it unlikely that he would have
become effie's mentor it might have also
been a little inappropriate if you ask
me after all snape was in love with lily
it may have looked a bit creepy if he
were to form a close relationship with
her daughter in any case i'd like to
think that he would have at least been
kind to effie in a way he never was with
harry you know in a plight british kind
of way so if i had my pick of mentors
for effie i'd have to go with the
obvious choice professor minerva
mcgonagall the transfiguration teacher
and head of gryffindor house with
guidance from mcgonagall maybe effie
would have become skilled at
transfiguration in a way that never
happened for harry perhaps she would
have even perfected her ability to
transform herself into an animal at will
and become an animagus like professor
mcgonagall this isn't too far-fetched
either especially since effie's
godfather sirius was also an animagus
effie grew up spending lots of time with
this version of sirius so maybe she
would have learned from an early age how
to transform herself into say a doe
after her mother's patronus once again
it looks like if harry had been a girl
life at hogwarts would not have been
filled with nearly as much doom and
gloom effie wouldn't have been involved
in a lot of the misadventures that
filled harry's days since as we covered
earlier in the video she would not have
been linked to voldemort like harry was
yes i think safe to say things would
have been a fair bit more carefree for
our effie with her focus at hogwarts
being mostly on her relationships and
school you know normal kid stuff of
course this would have likely come to a
halt when voldemort returned to power as
it did for all students at hogwarts
alongside hermione and ron she would
have been involved in dumbledore's army
led by neville longbottom and when
voldemort brought the fight to hogwarts
she would have fought alongside her
classmates in the battle and maybe even
witnessed fred's death urging george to
keep fighting amidst his grief in the
battlefield finally she would have been
on the front lines as neville finally
defeated voldemort later in the epilogue
we would find out that she had married
george perhaps they even named their
kids the same as harry and ginny did
james sirius albert severus and lily
luna potter on second thought maybe
molly or arthur snuck into one of those
names after all both the potters and the
weasleys were still alive which brings
us to the end of this video if you
enjoyed the content i'd be grateful if
you liked it and subscribe to the
channel as always happy to hear your
input on this and any other harry potter
theories just leave them in the comments
below also please feel free to share any
topics you'd like to see in upcoming
videos you guys always have great ideas
for more videos like this one be sure to
check out some of the other what if
theories like what if harry accepted
draco malfoy's handshake or what if
cedric diggory never died until next
time you're a witch effie
[Music]
you